so now here's an Incredible video so
this is a video at the white house
yesterday and there's a Reuters
journalist the woman that you're about
to see asking the question her name is
Andrea shawal she is part of the world
economic Forum well done snoops on the
internet uh it turns out she's a world
economic Forum affiliate so she works
for Reuters listen to the question the
leading question that she asks Karin
Jean-Pierre about Elon Musk and Twitter
and listen to I mean Corrine John Pierre
do I have to tell you what I think you
know what I think about her but listen
to her nonsense look at her body
language the eyes the whole thing just
it's all it's gross prepare yourself for
Pure grossness enjoy critical moment
really in terms of ensuring that Twitter
does not become a vector for
misinformation I mean are you concerned
about
the you know Elon Musk says there's more
and more subscribers coming online are
you concerned about that and what tools
do you have who is it at the White House
that is really keeping track of this so
look this is something that we're
certainly keeping an eye on and uh look
um we you know we have always been very
clear
and that when it comes to social media
platforms it is their responsibility to
make sure that when it comes to
misinformation when we when it comes to
the hate that we're seeing that they
they take action that they continue to
take action again we're all keeping a
close eye on this we're all monitoring
uh what's what's currently occurring and
we see you know we see it with our own
eyes of what you all are reporting and
just for for ourselves what's happening
on Twitter but again social media
companies have a responsibility to
prevent the their platforms from being
used by any user to incite violence
especially violence directed at
individual communities as we have been
seeing and the president has been very
clear on calling that out he'll continue
to do that and we're going to continue
to monitor the situation go ahead Mamma
Mia all right there's so much there so
just to be clear again the woman who
asked the question the journalist who
asked the question is in cahoots with
the world economic Forum what kind of
question is it when a journalist is
asking the White House Press Secretary
she's in essence saying hey can you guys
censor more can you figure out a way so
that people can't share what they think
and then cringe on peers answer and you
know her body language and the looking
down the entire time it's just such full
of nonsense
um she first she says that it is not
that it is their responsibility that
it's big text responsibility social
media platforms responsibility to watch
out for misinformation no it's not where
does it say that these are companies
that can do whatever they want we have
the Bill of Rights and the Constitution
that protect our rights right but it is
not their responsibility to do that you
might like them to do that and by the
way let's not forget the Jen saki she
told us that the White House Flags post
for Facebook so they are using big Tech
to encroach on your free speech and I
suspect that they know that Elon knows
it right because Elon right now has all
the records of what's going on at
Twitter over the last couple years and
do you think as he's flipping through
the records he's going boy this is odd
we got an email from someone and I'm
just giving an example here this is very
bizarre we got a email from somebody in
the administration uh who or from
intelligence Services who wanted us to
uh get rid of Donald Trump uh boy we
have something here from somebody in the
intelligence Services FBI CIA who wanted
us to hide the hunter buying laptop like
the whole Jig Is up I think Elon has the
keys to expose all of the craziness and
he's implying by the way that he's going
to do it so she says it's their
responsibility and that they should take
action well if you're forcing them to
take action then that isn't a direct
violation of the First Amendment right
it's not the government coming but if
the government forces a company to clamp
down on your free speech again what they
call it's disinformation or
misinformation even though they're the
Premier agents of the stuff this is a
problem